welcome to this video playing Alonso
mostly I think I am had asked him before
in a video where this name comes from
and it's from the movie Midnight Run
with Robert De Niro quite fun movie okay
we haven't known have an English opening
symmetrical English and he's played this
so-called board winning set up very very
solid way to to to play for for white I
didn't really have attend to that moves
quite uncommon you play h3y normally
early on to avoid that maybe I can n-no
I'm a bit you cannot Queen twins they
have can I have go on some some funny
funny business with HP for a three takes
d3 and F form
yeah maybe it's a it's a piece sack for
43 points of him he could have played a
3 and therefore as mentioned giving up
giving up them points for pieces okay
yeah maybe this is a simpler okay let's
return to the to the usual way to to
play this at least the night is not a
great honor for it means that the night
on f4 means that my night has got a
position only five and cannot so easily
be are expelled not quite sure that I
understand the rationale between taking
on b5 and playing a form yeah my idea
was to play before now maybe I was
playing this too quickly after takes
tags I've got queen bee six just a
tactical idea my D Phi by go east six as
well this was my idea may be bad at 10
okay this means it's not such a bad idea
at least it's not not not punished in
some in some way g4 is hanging and I can
also have to take just player play 94
Wow f5
and no it probably just take its easiest
and now Knight e5 or is there some
better news Queen B 6 check bishop asics
can also do that why not actually yeah I
have 6 i've got about f6 okay I'm so
better play this at the tech g-form so
he allows this check maybe it's not
fatal
yeah it's just a bunch of checks and
nautica not clear that it's really a
winning or anything
okay completely completely massive
position yeah John shouldn't I try as I
actually should just take it because um
it's not not just the exchange i hope i
hope i'm hoping for rook c5 to age five
quite funny these two points wait just
before I could meet him now well I think
if he's probably lost anyway i hope i
hope at least yeah it's the case g4 I've
got queen bee five and somewhere here
not sure that I we've seen that Queen f2
is easy i am queen f to assess winning
instantly yeah this better the problem
is i thought was not the truck c5 I
didn't really have I saw that g-force
but I didn't see em this Queen B 5 booth
I thought I don't have anything h5 t h5
terrible that's also winning okay yeah
you cannot many must get to get a look
on h8 or something to too matronly this
is always the problem you can't so
easily get mated here but this attack is
is quicker yeah very messy game I have
no idea what what was going on there
done computer thinks it's all equal
after this black is better okay yeah
very good game I hope you liked it
thanks